oh that is good if you're ready
right-handed assume I'm gonna do that
just dance button I'm the red person it
was waiting for the right hand of sore
on whoa which color alive am i doing
something right now all right so that's
you I'm red oh my god what it's
complicated difficult you wait oh yeah
well you have to move together draw
believe hot down there sorry oh you
think I lower Jesus Christ what Oh what
da hell be like if I I don't even know
this is even more this is wile are you
guys even showing the gameplay oh wait
now we switch Oh what the [ __ ] get your
Rob uh yeah Oh get me huh no wait I'm no
no this is wrong no it's fine we got you
your goodie guy you're going again hello
the good I got his head I got a snack
fun no no we're gonna go
that's like this like your appetizer
this isn't Dancing this is dancing
whether you like it or not is I'm
thankful are you yeah I'm blue I think
it's recognizing it Heba what your legs
run like what the heck's you have your
legs robbed oh just how we plan is my
guys is that he'll just dance 4 reasons
oh yes you in the face almost what is
this Oh high score
oh man you lose game oh wow I'm sorry
that you had to be the guy who gets
stomped on six thousand points baby
perfect fit funky funky no funky you can
get out you could have done a little bit
more funky where I know those awesome
hopefully oh it's got you up there we go
oh um it's got highly Oh at the end you
guys don't put that phone great they're
all important moments if one of us ends
up murdering somebody this is the
footage of the police XOX record that
xbox ping the matrix Xbox Bing the
matrix Tony checking out your button
that one I know what I'm doing when
you're on and connect so great work
everybody you're working at work what's
thought that was flawless great cuz I'm
I get the big boy chair all right that's
the lobby for this
you